- [Group] Quinta versus feminism!
- You know, as Gwen Stefani has said,
it's my life, don't you forget.
(applauding)
- So great.
Okay, I think we have time
for one more question?
Yeah, right there.
- This question's for Quinta.
Quinta, you're such a strong woman.
What are some moments
that have compromised
your ideas of feminism, and
how did you deal with that?
♪ Tell me what to do Daddy ♪
♪ Shake that ass girl ♪
♪ Bend it over girl ♪
♪ Count my money ♪
- That one's on me.
- Oh, oh, thanks, cool.
Hey Quinta.
- Yeah?
- Walk me to the bathroom?
- Okay, you want me to bring your drink?
- Oh, no, you know what, I
should be able to leave that
wherever I want, because, you know,
no one should put anything in it.
Because that's feminism.
- Okay.
Nah, I'ma bring your drink!
- I wanna be a video dancer
turned rapper just like Cardi B.
- Of course she is.
- She's always trying to comfort somebody.
- But I like Azealia Banks, though.
I don't think she's that bad.
- You know, Caitlyn Jenner
is a beautiful woman,
she is so brave.
- [Woman] Yeah, totally agree.
♪ Tell me what to do daddy ♪
- How about Gabrielle Union?
She's a good role model, right?
- Nah, I like Nicki Minaj.
And Kylie Jenner!
- Okay, no.
- Hillary would have been the answer.
I can't believe we all voted
for her and she didn't win.
- We didn't all vote for her.
Well, I mean I voted for her
in the primaries of course,
after she won, but upfront I wasn't voting
for nobody's Hillary.
I'm just saying,
Taylor Swift's music
video wasn't that bad.
I'm just saying it wasn't
a bad music video, Freddie!
It wasn't bad!
I don't know how to put this.
While those women are all great,
if you grew up to be like one of them,
I don't know what I'll do.
And there's a chance I might disown you.
- That's not very feminist of you.
- I know, I'm working on it.
(clearing throat)
Well, you know what, I
still think Sex and the City
is a good show, but I make up for it
by just listening to some Beyonce.
(audience cheering)
- [Group] Quinta versus babies!
- His hands are legal weapons.
- He could go to prison.
- He will go to prison.
But he finished my massage,
and he was super strong
because he used to be an
ex-boxer and I was a little
scared but I tried not
to think about, Quinta?
- Mm-hmm?
- Quinta, what are you looking at?
- Him.
- That little baby?
- It's not a baby.
It's a child, and it,
he, he's lookin' at me.
(laughing)
Okay, this game, he's lying, Kate.
He's a liar.
- He's a kid.
- Don't be fooled, that's
how Trump got elected.
Now look at us, losing the DACABC.
- What the actual hell
are you talking about?
- He's making his dino-nuggets eat me.
Like I'm (beeping) dino chow.
All right, I'm gonna count to three,
and I want you to turn around
and catch him in the act okay.
One.
- Quinta, I don't care.
- Two.
- Quinta.
- Three, look Kate, look, look, look.
(giggling)
- He really is so cute!
- Oh, He just winked at me, that's it.
- [Kate] Quinta, what are you doing?
- Don't worry about it.
What's up little man?
What's up, not so bad now
that I'm here, are you?
- Excuse me, can we help you?
- Yes, thank you for
parenting, Dina Lohan.
Your son's a menace.
You too sir, you're not off the hook.
- Uh, did he do something?
- Uh, he is making his
dino-nuggets eat me.
And he's looking at me.
- I'm sorry, he's at a very playful age.
He's a toddler.
- Do something, do something about it.
- Jacob, apologize to the lady.
- I'm sorry.
- Thank you, that's all
I wanted, all right.
You guys have a great day.
- I thought you were
another kid to play with me
because you're so short.
- Oh you gon' learn today.
You gon' learn!
- Well where do you wanna
get wings now, buddy?
- Have you ever been to KFC?
- Yeah, I'm not extraterrestrial.
- Okay, let's go there.
- Okay.
- [Quinta] Hey the colonel,
is he white or black?
(dance music)
- [Group] Quinta versus pregnancy!
- He's not here yet.
I'm whispering because
you're not supposed to be
on the phone in a doctor's office.
There's a sign that says it.
Guess the office will crash
like a plane or something.
I'm feeling okay, I'm fine.
I love you too.
Let's not talk about naming it.
Michael's cute, I like that.
No, not Jermaine, no other Jacksons.
What is with you and the
Jacksons, oh gotta go.
Hi!
- Don't sweat it, it's a dumb rule.
- I'm so sorry.
- It keeps the noise down,
we're all on our phones
all the time anyway.
- Okay, cool.
- I'm on Tinder when I
don't have a patient.
- Really, You Tinder?
You must clean up on that bad boy, huh?
Doctor, USC grad.
- How do you know I went to USC?
Yeah, actually they have been bad lately.
Dates have been bad.
- Really?
- Yeah, I don't think I'm
enough of a (bleep) boy.
(laughs)
- Sorry, wanna get a
mental image of my doctor
saying (bleep) boy, that is good.
- [Doctor] Guess I'm a
little too old and doctor-y
for that one.
- I think you're too doctor-y for that.
- Got it.
All right, well enough about me.
You are not pregnant.
- Wow, okay.
- Yeah, you came in because
of the missed period?
- Yeah.
- Or the spotty one, rather?
Well, you're anemic.
- Oh, yeah, I forgot about that.
- Yeah you can't forget.
Because you've gotta get your iron in
or everything go out of
whack, including your period.
- Right, all right, I'll be on top of it.
- And why didn't you take a pregnancy test
before coming in here?
- Oh, I did, Shawty
just wanted to be sure.
- Got it, and are we having protected sex
with the boyfriend?
- I am, we aren't.
(chuckles)
- Ah, okay, I think we're good.
- [Quinta] Okay.
- It's not baby time yet.
- Awesome.
- Would you mind helping
me with my dating life?
- Really?
- Yeah, could use it.
- Okay, all right, sure.
I'm gonna charge you double
what you charged me, though.
- Does my copay apply?
- No.
All right, you know what
maybe you wanna take
scuba diving lover out of your bio,
Because if I saw that
I'd actually report you.
You know, save that for month three.
You don't wanna intro with that.
That's something you save
for the third act, okay cool.
Call me millennial, 'cause
I got nothing in the oven.
- Oh, um, nice, cool, that's great.
Now I don't have to drink
the entire wine collection by myself.
And we get to go to Vegas.
- You weren't gonna stop drinking with me?
- No.
- Wow, damn!
- I'm joking, of course I would've.
- Where are you?
it sounds echo-y
- Oh, uh, the attic?
- Why?
- I was just looking around,
seeing if we could use the
space as a different room.
- Well that's something.
- Yeah.
- Tonight, would you just
wanna have some wine,
and maybe go see a movie,
or we could stay in,
whatever you wanna do?
- Smoke some weed?
- Yes, yes, and plan our Vegas trip.
We should get one of those
rooms that has the bar in it,
but it's not a mini-bar, it's just free.
Yeah.
(upbeat dance music)